all right so we had the first um uh
installment of these january 6 trump
riot hearings last thursday night which
i covered live and then today was
scheduled to be the second hearing
starting at 10 a.m eastern and just as
it's time to start we learned that bill
stephen trump's former campaign manager
is refusing to show up initially a lot
of the headlines were as though he was
doing something legally wrong or just
bailing but that's not actually the case
it turns out that bill stephen's wife
went into labor a legitimate reason not
to show up the real question now is
what's going to come from these hearings
in the coming two weeks and we will
discuss that but first i do want to tell
you about our sponsor aura many people
are shocked when their identity is
stolen but it's actually one of the
fastest growing crimes in the u.s i've
dealt with it it's a terrible feeling
and that's why i now protect myself with
oro aura monitors email addresses
passwords social security number bank
accounts credit cards and i can set it
up to instantly get an alert on my phone
if something happens and then aura goes
through the process of fixing it as well
aura also does things like make sure no
one's opening up bank accounts or credit
cards in your name or it takes all the
tools you need to protect all of your
accounts and devices puts them in one
easy app identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com pacman you
can try aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email password
right now and you can find out for free
i found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below
alright so there are two perspectives on
these trump riot hearings
one perspective is
nobody's going to watch
nobody cares even if people did watch
nothing notable or newsworthy is going
to come out of them it's a witch hunt
it's more of the same rusher rusher
rusher you remember i don't even know
where the word division is there as
trump pronounces it
um and it's uh part of the left wing
mob
woke
you know crt and insert whatever uh
catch phrases you want that's one side
the other side is people and i know some
of these people myself who say this is
it that everybody's getting arrested
trump's about to be perp walked he's
going to end up in prison because of
what's going to be exposed here
as as it may not shock you to hear my
perspective is that the truth
lies in between those two extremes
from
liz cheney sort of gave an outline on
thursday night about what each day is
going to contain so we already know what
they're going to do and she previewed
some of the most explosive evidence so
a ton of the evidence that they're going
to present text messages
and statements made during testimony
we have already seen reporting on
uh when it was oh kaylee mcinanni was
texting with hannity and it was all this
whole
that already leaked or was released so a
ton of the stuff they're going to do
we're already aware of
many in the united states may not be
aware of it because maybe they don't
cover they don't follow this stuff as
closely as people in my audience would
so that stuff isn't going to be new but
it's going to be new to a lot of people
that potentially are going to watch
these hearings are the hearings going to
have the best ratings no
but are they going to get no audience
definitely not i believe that the first
night got 22 million on broadcast tv
plus endless millions online i mean you
looked at you looked at streamers me uh
ian vausch and all sorts of other people
everybody had big audiences so there is
interest now who is watching is a
separate question so i think there will
be a good audience and a bunch of the
people are going to be hearing a lot of
this stuff for the first time in
addition
we are going to get
new uh testimony and evidence for
example liz cheney
mentioned in her introduction on
thursday
that we will hear testimony during the
hearings of people who say they were in
the room when trump was told the crowd
is chanting hang mike pence and that
trump reportedly said well maybe he
should be hanged that's new that had not
previously leaked and that is completely
outrageous now whether that
leads to a criminal referral is a
totally different thing so let's deal
with that part
last
um i spoke to congressman jamie raskin
who's on the committee a few weeks ago
and i said do you expect criminal
charges to come out of this do you think
your colleagues members of the house
should be worried about criminal charges
and he didn't really answer and that's
not surprising but what he did say was
that's not actually the role their the
role of the house is investigative and
if in the course of doing the
investigation
crimes or apparent crimes or evidence of
crimes comes up
they refer it to the justice department
and it's up to the justice department to
go from there from the early commentary
legal commentaries that have surfaced in
the last 24 hours before i recorded this
video
it does seem as though many people are
saying what's there
is sufficient for a criminal referral on
trump
that's not me saying trump's getting
indicted and it's not me saying if trump
gets indicted he's going to be convicted
all i'm saying is there are commentaries
saying this is so outrageous and they've
got him so dead to rights
that this is going to lead to charges at
the same time part of it is about more
about georgia than about these hearings
so
if i was a betting man and you just say
david even odds okay
you're not getting you're not getting
odds it's just
straight up
are there charges against trump or not
i still go with no
but i'm only at about 55 45. and many of
you who have been writing in and calling
in for years saying david why do you
keep saying you people write to me with
tears in their eyes i know that when
they're writing they're crying they
write to me with tears in their eyes and
they say sir
why don't you think there will be
charges
i have seen no evidence that there is
any willingness to bring charges against
trump i'm still on the no charges side
but by a very small margin 55 45
and i believe me i would love it if
charges were brought um maybe after this
week of hearings my perspective will
change so let me know in the comments
number one
will you be watching the hearings have
you been watching the hearings and
number two
um do you believe that criminal charges
are forthcoming for a failed former
president donald trump